("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Metanoia 2" (Prod. Spacio))
- [Gary] If you woke
up this morning
and heard
Entourage is getting rebooted
with a little
bit more diversity,
so it's five guys, right
let's diverse it a little up.
Black dude, Latino dude, and
then three white dudes, right?
And it's a Netflix reboot.
Like we just woke up
and they're like, it's back.
New show, same shit.
Instead of going to CAA,
the guy went to WME.
Like literally like, a different
Ari, his name's Shmari,
like same shit right?
- [Man] Darker Israeli guy.
- Exactly, like
if you'd heard that,
okay so now that show on
Netflix, that quality video,
that show, an hour
episode each episode.
Now imagine three minutes and
six seconds from that episode,
a clip from three
minutes and six seconds where,
where they're
just wearing your thing
or whatever they're doing just
three minutes and six seconds
from Entourage 2017.
If you make that video and put
it on Facebook and it works,
it'll change your business.
("Metanoia 2" (Prod. Spacio))
You're running
quant CAC, hardcore math
on digital and social,
and then you're running
TV remnip for brand,
but the reality is
the birth child of that,
the birth child of that is
fucking Facebook commercials.
So like, we're killing it.
So like, as a complete side note
so let me tell you
why I built VaynerMedia.
I'm building
VaynerMedia so that I can
buy Lacoste for $233 million
and run it through my machine,
which is why it
sounds like you might be,
so it's funny, we're
just, for the first time
getting into
non-Fortune 100 clients.
Sounds like you're at
enough scale that we should,
whether it's a client of Vayner,
whether it's a Vayner Sports
thing that gets you access,
whether it's just
me getting to know you,
whether it's advisory shares,
whether it's friendship,
like leverage for 50 years,
I definitely can tell you this.
What you do is what
I think about 24/7/365
and there's three
things you should be doing,
and you're onto it.
You're doing it in a department,
you're doing it like this.
You're doing the math right
to the best of your ability,
and you're doing brand,
that's why you're doing sports,
that's why you're doing TV.
I'm telling you right now,
like children's
life on the table.
The birth child on
Facebook will change.
Hold on, even better.
You have the proof, that's
why everybody in your office
is talking about me.
That's what I'm doing.
Like I laugh at when
clients are like, are you sure?
I'm like, why'd you come here?
They're like, well you.
I'm like, bingo.
Real pleasure.
I'll see you buddy,
thank you so much, thank you.
Yeah, good to see you.
- You too.
Good to see you.
("Metanoia 2" (Prod. Spacio))
- Love it, yeah.
Take a look, okay?
And then all of a sudden, my
calendar says 1:00 to 1:20
and you know, LA meetings and
then they send me an email
saying these are who's there.
You gotta learn how to,
by the way, when
I say you gotta learn,
I literally just made this up.
It's something
I've never thought of before.
But this is why,
this is why we can't lose.
All we have to
do is communicate.
I love that you just
brought this up, right.
To me, it's having the
priorities in the right place
and then we're good,
you know what I mean?
I can deal with anything,
as long as I feel like
we're trying to
win the right game.
The DM, people don't understand,
the best business
development opportunity
in a long time, since probably
'07, '08 Twitter, you know,
or early blogging
2002, '03, '04,
when tech leaders
had blogs and they'd put
their email up there and they
were actually answering them.
You get these moments
for a year or two or three
where you get
access to anybody you want
that sits on higher pedestals
than you or hot or interesting
and people are
already tuning out DM
because they get bombarded.
I have, for the most part.
I'm trying, so we
got six months to a year
and everybody's
gonna regret not using
the DM move that I'm
trying to tell them to do.
("Metanoia 2" (Prod. Spacio))
- We just started.
- [Gary] I gotta go.
I love you.
- We're just starting.
- I love you.
(kissing)
I'm super available.
You could talk to me anytime.
Well, you came super late.
- Much better.
- [Gary] Good.
Alright, see you later.
- [Man 2] Drive safe.
- [Gary] Okay, let's find out.
I also think this a good place
top play my model, right?
Where we make two commercials,
but we pick up a shit load
of micro-content out of it,
and we've got a
year's worth of content.
You know?
I've got a couple ideas.
This whole thing I'm riding
on, just to give you context,
this whole hashtag waving,
like you know, thirsty Thursday
or motivational Monday
or Thursday thoughts.
There's things
that always trend,
and we could be
very smart and efficient
and get a lot of extra organics,
so we'll figure it out.
But like, you know,
the model right now
for Vayner is our
execution off a brief market
is very much the Facebook
commercials with influencers
layered on top and
some sort of culture hacking
like Alexa voice
or what have you.
So whether it's all
influence or whether it's
three commercials with
800 pieces of micro-content
that comes out of it.
I mean, I'm sitting
with DRock right now.
I'm thinking to
myself, like, truth is
that in a 22 minute DailyVee,
there's probably three
months worth of content
if we really wanted to.
We get like three
days out of it now,
but if it was our only lifeline.
Like, so there's a lot
of things we can create
in this environment.
("Metanoia 2" (Prod. Spacio))
The stuff that you
people don't know about.
As much as we're sharing.
DRock, you really are getting,
you're really getting
the MBA on how to run shit.
What most
people don't understand
is that real A and B
list talent have no time.
J.Lo doesn't have time, right?
Jeter doesn't have time.
You know, Rhianna
doesn't have time,
and this model is
actually built more
for those people than
it is for the entrepreneurs
that have
jumped on first, right?
I think it's about
building ultimate brand
and attention at scale, which
then leads to opportunity.
I will tell you this.
I firmly believe
that 50% of the people
that would buy this package
would make back their investment
in their advance on a book
deal and on their speaking,
and that's when
I started getting confident
to actually do it, right?
Like, Max, listen.
I know enough about you,
and you've been doing
some really clever stuff.
I just think it
works for anybody.
I mean you've gotta
be able to afford it,
and thus, that goes into
a different stratosphere,
but I'm trying to
build actual brand
in a world where
I think most people.
You know what I think
happened with me, Max,
to be very frank?
I think most
people are salespeople,
and I think I'm a
marketer and a brander.
I built a brand, and I didn't
cash in in the short term,
and so the
investment was worth it.
And I think there's a lot of
smart individuals out there
who realize fuck it,
I'll pour in a million dollars
over four years, get 40%
of what Gary got our of it
because of
personality differences,
and I'll make
that ROI positive back.
Because if you
believe what I believe,
which is the
cellphone is the new television
and Facebook and Instagram
and Snapchat and YouTube
are ABC, NBC and CBS, well then,
you're trying
to become Seinfeld,
and some people become Seinfeld,
and other people
become Charles in Charge.
I think I've proven
over the last decade
that I understood how
content on the internet
works contextual
to the moment in time
and the formats and the nuances
of the platforms, right?
We're not guessing here.
We're not just
filming and putting it out.
Like copy creative
quotes, like, you know.
It's a good observation
by you, and I'm flattered
'cause I really
do respect your POV.
I've upped my game
in the last 18 months.
(rattling)
Hold on one second, Max.
- [Nicole] You're GaryVee.
- I am.
- I'm looking at you like I
swear he looks like GaryVee.
- How are you?
- Hey, nice to
meet you, Nicole Jansen.
- Hey, Nicole, how are you?
- I'm doing great,
I'm just doing a workshop
over at Next Space, so.
- Awesome, such a pleasure.
- [Nicole] I didn't
mean to interrupt.
- No worries.
Thanks for saying hello.
- GaryVee,
what's going on, man?
Follow you
every day, brother.
- Thank you, brother.
Love you, pal, see ya.
Talk to ya.
Bye, bye.
Like, reality is
it doesn't matter.
What I did was a
little bit different
if you kinda look
at the macro 10 years,
I didn't do any of that.
I just went to the end consumer,
and now I have all the leverage.
("Metanoia 2" (Prod. Spacio))
Ugh.
Did not think that
those feature sets
have slowed the
momentum of growth
in what I would call the
35- to 55-year-old demo.
And so, I still think,
it's not been
a full year, and
I think a lot of these
things tend to take
a year to understand.
But I do think
it's kind of like,
it's on Snapchat now
to come back with other
variables, so,
I don't know it's an
intriguing question
because I think people
are very naive
and don't realize how
strong Snapchat is
under 30, right, and really
under 25.
Right?
I mean that's the punchline.
Who says that
Snapchat can't create a feature
tomorrow that
really hurts Linkedin for
business kids under 30,
I don't know, right?
So, I think flexibility
of content always matters
so, what's the written word,
what's audio?
What does audio
look like on Snapchat?
What if Snapchat
tomorrow, created unlimited
length of a Snap in audio?
I would tell you
the next second, I would
put the GaryVee
podcast on Snapchat
and push it like crazy.
So I'm very fascinated by audio.
I think audio is a
place where Snapchat
could go and say
"Okay everybody produces
"long form audio
because that's growing,
"on a single Snap, you
could have unlimited audio,"
I would be populating
my Snapchat stories so
aggressively with long
form audio and catering
it to an under 40 demo
and that would be huge.
So that's one
random idea I just made up.
They should, they should.
But I'm not in the
business of guessing,
I'm in the business of
making the right marketing
decisions in the
second that I'm breathing.
I don't care.
Gary's cool.
'Cause Gary's the coolest.
(laughs)
Just to define this
for the vlog, so they know,
cool as "I'm the most empathetic
"and understanding if
somebody can't do something."
I know, I was doing
that for the camera Todd
I know you know.
("Metanoia 2" (Prod. Spacio))
- Hey, Lance.
Nice to meet you.
- Lance, how are ya?
- Good, man.
- My pleasure, sit.
How's your day going?
- It's going great.
- It's super important.
I mean you know, the
cliche thing with
agencies is I hate
departments
because everybody gets into
their silos, but
if you don't know what
the fuck is
actually happening in the
consumer's head,
it doesn't matter.
You already lost
when you go to create.
("Metanoia 2" (Prod. Spacio))
- Oh yeah, I guess
one thing that I've talked
to people about is
how you can communicate
between offices or
among offices more.
Like how can you
connect people who are
not in the same place.
- Yes.
- Do you have
any plans in place at
the moment for that?
- Yes and no.
So, if you look
across every company and
the great benefit
of being an investor in
a lot of companies and
having a lot of clients
is, it's a challenge.
There's no technology,
there's no Yammer, or Slack
or whatever
that's going to fix it.
And there's no, you
know, other things like
buddy systems or
cross-pollinating one weeks
in other offices.
They're really band-aids,
and they're really optics.
They make people
feel like the company
cares about it.
I would tell you a
much smarter thing to do
and this is what I
always tell people that
communicate to me, is
that you should send me
an email of what
you're yearning for and
then let me
create a custom plan.
I'd rather create
a custom plan for 700
than to check the
box for the entire
company that I know
then doesn't get done.
- Right, okay.
- I'm not one who does
things to appease the masses
to show the optics that we care
I'd rather actually solve it.
And so there's 483
people who don't give a fuck
but for the 210 that do,
I wanna figure it out.
And so, if you feel
disconnected from the
rest of the media team,
I'd rather understand
how you feel that.
What, in detail,
does it feel like.
And then if it's like
"Oh, when their system
"changes we are two days behind"
I want to see the
nuances, then try to solve.
Either in a
manifesto in one email now
or as it pops up in
your head, when you feel it
email me.
- Okay. Cool.
- Awesome.
Such a pleasure.
- Thank you so much.
- Have a great day, it was
really nice meeting you.
- You know it's funny.
I think everything is censored.
Like everything that's
wrong here is my fault.
Because that's just how shit is.
But I also think good
things happen cause of that.
So for example,
I'm scared
shitless of negativity.
I hate that shit.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- And so, I'm
not gonna let like,
it would just fuck me up.
- [Man 3] Right.
- So, like, I love
when I hear that from you.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- Because that's like fuck yes.
Like thank you God.
Like that's what I want.
- [Man 3] Right.
- That's the
Honey Empire which is
I still want to be great but if
you can't fucking
art direct and you suck,
like fuck, what
do you want me to do?
- [Man 3] Right?
- But, I don't care if
you're fucking Pablo Picasso,
if you're a dick face,
you're getting
the fuck outta here.
(both laugh)
- [Man 3] Yeah. I appreciate
also like the candor.
I think everybody
here is pretty much like
I've been to other
jobs where people, like,
hold back who they really were.
- Sure.
- [Man 3] And, here you're
just kinda like okay
boom, boom, boom.
You know.
We'll be in meetings
people will just be like,
you know saying something,
yeah, if they
don't fucking get it.
You know what I mean?
It's just like.
Yeah, and it's cool.
So like the
culture here's kinda like
I get it, it's cool.
- It fits you.
- [Man 3] Yeah,
and it fit's me as well.
So this is the first gig
that I ever ran where I'm--
- Makes me happy.
That makes me happy brother.
Listen, here's why,
here's why I had this meeting.
When shit doesn't go
as well, you email me.
- [Man 3] Alright.
- Do you understand?
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- I'm here to fix shit.
("Tales Of LA" by Jay)
I think we also
overthink a lot of stuff.
We don't need the
map to the mothership.
We aren't, we don't
have to have our own.
Like, it's just good.
Let's stop overthinking shit.
Like, you know where a place is?
I look at you equal to
a CM in London as I do to
the Head of Media in New York.
Like, it's agnostic flat.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- Like, we're a company.
- One team.
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm.
- In my mind.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- Of course
everyone thinks in LA or
in TV or in paid media.
I know what humans do but
that's not what it's gonna be.
Not what
decisions are being made on.
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm.
You know?
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
("Tales Of LA" by Jay)
- [Gary] The very
heady theoretical.
- [Woman 3] Definitely.
- This one has a
lot more practicality.
- [Woman 3] For sure.
- By the way they both matter.
- [Woman 3] They do.
- The problem is the
important one is yours, old one.
The problem is it's not true
until it sees the light of day.
All the creative
world does is debate it
prior to the
reality of it coming out.
- [Woman 3] Right.
- Which is inefficient itself.
- [Woman 3] Are you sure?
- It's just very real to me.
Like, I'm so excited.
I think I gonna build the
greatest creative
agency of all time
out of a theory
that allows creatives to
actually have a lot of
at-bats to be creative.
("Tales Of LA" by Jay)
- [Gary] Don't get it confused.
Yeah, there's a
lot more influencers.
There's a lot more eyeballs.
Guys, do you know
how many people watch a
cable television show?
20,000.
Like an average.
Like, a lot.
Especially for you guys 'cause
you're like young in it.
You know, it's like.
You can't imagine how much
bigger it is than
the real world.
- [Matthew] Yeah.
- It's wild.
("Tales Of LA" by Jay)
Yeah, real pleasure.
Hustle.
- Keep hustlin'.
- I'm using one of your ideas.
- Good.
- If someone was,
if someone was like,
yo do this thing
that Gary's doing.
I was like what is Gary doing?
So I went and I looked at it.
It was in the first,
I stopped doing it,
I'm gonna do it again this week.
- Yep.
- But, the first minute
having comments on it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So as soon as I
starting doing it.
Shit what?
It worked?
That shit works?
(laughter)
("Tales Of LA" by Jay)
- Closing you out.
Red eyes.
I promised
myself no more red eyes.
I've done four this year.
(DRock laughs)
Fucking joke.
Gotta make sure your actions
back up you fucking mouth.
("Tales Of LA" by Jay)